[Music]
this is a keeper of a recipe for me it's
something that you would see in Puerto
Rico or the Dominican Republic during
Thanksgiving or Christmas hi I'm kan
Sean and today I'm gonna be making a
spiced delicious Indian inspired rack of
lamb with a Middle Eastern twist I'm JJ
Johnson we're gonna spice it up a little
bit the lamb I'm bringing pav stella's
it's a little bit of plantain masa
some ground beef it's gonna be super
tasty the recipe that I chose to make
today has been a family favorite
except I created an interesting twist my
grandma used to use white poppy seeds
for richness and creaminess and I
honestly couldn't find those here so I
decided to substitute cashews for that
same creamy luxurious effect most North
Indian recipes involving any kind of
meat usually use a nut or a seed for
richness I just love how this dish
represents my grandmother the cultural
and historical lens through which she
cooked and how I can put that on my
modern family table and still honor her
is a really special offering for my
family so a lot of northern Indian meat
dishes and meat curries are influenced
by the persian culinary perspective
because of all these amazing historical
influences that India experienced so
this dish I would say something we call
a moogly dish because it has yogurt it
has all those rich spices and it has the
creaminess of the nuts the sumac is not
really a spice that we use in India but
I love it and I think it goes so
beautifully with lamb for me
Thanksgiving is definitely about the
food but it's also about family and
friends coming together around the feast
and really being able to dive in that's
why I love this rack of lamb it's just
so amenable to sharing family-style
literally the king your fingers as you
did I just love the idea of celebrating
food through a historical lens for me
the fact that I can put this dish that
represents my grandmother hoard cultural
perspective on my family table just
makes it a really rich moment where we
can honor our
and culinary traditions my recipe today
is called pasteles it's something that
you would see in Puerto Rico or
Dominican Republic it is similar to a
tamale with plantains and yucca and
butternut squash it's something that you
would see in anyone's freezer of a
Puerto Rican or a Dominican touring
Thanksgiving or Christmas it's a ritual
something we all have and we all look
forward to eating this dish is super
special to my heritage I would see my
grandmother's and my great aunts making
this in the fall season and freezing it
in the freezer it truly meant that it
was becoming that special time of the
year when family was coming together I
consider myself a real child of the
African Diaspora my dad is
african-american my mom is Puerto Rican
and West Indian through the holidays
certain dishes on the table would define
who we are as a culture Thanksgiving and
Christmas we would always have pastels
on the table and that would always
remind us that we were from the Puerto
Rican descent and this was something
that you really wouldn't buy in a
grocery store or something that you
would get at a restaurant this is
something that you know grandmas and
auntie's were making across the globe as
I'm cooking the pasta Ella
it's truly bringing me back to my
childhood moments in life the holiday
season for me was always a big time of
the year you know being a chef for
Thanksgiving I've always been in a
restaurant cooking now that I have
children I cherish these moments with
them it means a lot to have big table
with a lot of family and friends eating
around that table and considered to me
some of the best moments in life so my
spices some are traditional and some are
untraditional in the meat mixture I'm
using Tatar spice ginger powder and
coriander and a little bit of hot spices
you're getting the real JJ swag through
your pasta I chose that are because I
spent some time in Israel and I fell in
love with the spice but especially how
it's in ground beef or ground meats I
think it goes really beautiful with
plantains all the aroma is the strong
flavor of it so I just wanted to
highlight it in this recipe I've
traveled to the melting pots of the
world
Singapore Israel Ghana in West Africa
India and I've seen a correlation of how
people have been able to move and then
mix and mingle and incorporate flavors
and you see that through my cooking the
folding technique of the pastel is you
really want to get in a rectangle so
what I do I put the plantain masa in the
middle carve out a little section to add
my meat filling and then I fold then I
tie with butchers twine so you want to
wrap the paw Stella the same way you
would wrap a ribbon around the present I
prefer not to tie that pasteles I'm just
not good with the butcher's twine this
is also a great dish to make with your
family you can line the banana leaves
across the table and somebody can pour
in the plantain masa somebody else can
put in the filling and then you can have
somebody fold and then whoever's really
good at making ribbons can tie the PAS
Stella when you get your pasta on the
table its wrapped in the banana leaf you
untie it personally I want to fill the
table with family members so they can
truly have this joyous moment this is
finger licking good just what I like to
hear
Happy Hanukkah be holidays
[Music]
Oh oh yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]